[音楽]
明日友達に話せる宇宙豆知識スーパー
ノヴァ編
最後ピシッと決めますので明日友達に話せ
そうか
認定をお願いいたします私たち人間は様々
な元素でできています例えば
酸素そして炭素水素しかし私たち人間が
いる宇宙は一番最初生まれたての頃は
ほとんど水素とヘリウムしかなかったと
考えられていますではどうしてそこから
私たちの人間にあるような
炭素や酸素水素のような元素が生まれたの
でしょうか
その数がスーパーノヴァという天体現象に
なります日本語では超新星爆発これは
星が一生を終える時に
起こすような天体現象なんですがでは普段
の星は何をしているのかと言うと
核融合反応という反応で熱や光を出してい
ます
核融合反応は例えば水素がヘリウムになっ
てヘリウムがベリリウムになってそういっ
た新しい
元素を作るといった反応なんですね
ことはこの宇宙が誕生してから最初の星が
できますそして核融合反応を起こします中
の材料がなくなると超新星爆発を起こして
超新星爆発で
星の中でできたガスが
宇宙空間ばらまかれますそしてまた新しい
星ができて
核融合反応してそして超新星爆発を起こし
てそういった
元素のバトンの受け渡しのようなものを
繰り返し行いながら長い時間かけた結果
私たちのような太陽そして地球が生まれて
そして地球の上に
偶然私たちのような
炭素な酸素などを持つ元素を持つ人間が
生まれたと考えられていますつまり
私たち人間はフィクションではなくて本当
に
星から生まれた子供なんです
ギリギリでしたね
ギリギリ
ギリギリ話せそうですかねありがとう
ございますということで改めまして良かっ
たと申しますどうぞよろしくお願いします
ありがとうございますありがとうござい
ますちょっと長めでしたね豆知識にしては
私はですね普段東京大学の天文学専攻と
いうところで天文学を研究している大学院
生ですそれと同時にYouTubeなどを
中心に天文学
宇宙星空に関する発信活動を行っており
ます私がこういった発信する活動に本腰を
入れ始めたきっかけがありましてそれは私
が大学3年生の頃でしたその時にある方に
出会ったんですねそれが
縣秀彦さんという方です
国立天文台の准教授の方でこの方は天文学
と社会とのより良い関係を考えるそういっ
た内容の研究をされている方なんですねで
私大学3年生の時に永田さんのお話を
初めて聞きましてなんかピンと来たんです
よねあ私もこういう人になりたいなって
思ったのが
講演会で安達さんに出会った時でしたこう
いったように私も天文学を発信するような
活動をやってみたいこんな姿になりたいな
そう思ったのが大学3年生の頃ですその時
にですね
講演会が終わったら同じ会場で
縣さんが書いてた本が売ってたんですよな
のでそのまま購入してですねそして本の
表紙開いてペンと一緒に縣さんのところ
持ってってここにサインくれませんかって
いう風にですね言ったのが今でも
覚えている思い出になります
そんな憧れの人との出会いがきっかけで私
は天文学を発信する
研究しながら発信するという活動に
取り組んでいきました
さて
テレックス名古屋遊2023のテーマは
スーパーノヴァですここに込められている
思いこちらですね
星々が
爆発していくように自分の殻を破り新たな
星として輝くように無限の可能性に気づく
そしてあなたが何かをしなきゃと一歩を
踏み出す
ということをですね天体現象としての超
新星爆発と対応させているんだなと思うん
ですがいやこれ
素敵なテーマですよねいやこれ本当に
すごいなと思ってるんですがただですね
私たち人間が無限の可能性に気づくとか一
歩を踏み出すっていうことはなかなか簡単
なことではないじゃないかなと思いますだ
からこそ今回の手で2023があるんだと
は思いますがスーパーノヴァ超新星爆発は
条件が揃えば基本的に必ず起こりますこう
いう条件で挑戦性爆発を起こす決まってい
ますただ私たち人間って無限の可能性に
気づくとか一歩を踏み出すということが
自動的にできるわけではないですよね
じゃあこういったことをするために私たち
はどうすれば良いのでしょうかそのヒント
を今日は天文学に求めてみたいと思います
早速ですが皆さんとお越しくださっている
皆さんと
星
宇宙との関わりについて聞いてみたいと
思うんですが皆さん最近
星って見ましたかじゃあ限定しましょうか
ここ1週間で
星を1回以上見ましたっていう人を手挙げ
ていただけますか
星をここ1週間で見ましたあーちらほら
ですねありがとうございますもちろんです
ね
星を見ないことが悪いというわけでは
もちろんありませんこの後絶対星見てねっ
て調整することもいませんもう一つ聞き
ましょうかもう少し広くして正座にし
ましょうかじゃあ今度は名前を知っている
星座がですね1個以上あるって言う方やめ
てください名前を知ってる正座が1個以上
あるあーありがとうございます結構多い
ですねさっきの56倍はいたのかなと思い
ますけどこちらはもちろんですね知らない
ことが悪いとかそういう話ではありません
星空はテストではないのでということは
ですね今日お越しくださっている方は
星座の名前は知っている方は多いけど最近
星を見たという方は少ないそういった方な
のかなということが分かりましたただです
ね中にはこう思った方もいらっしゃるかも
しれませんいや
星なんて山奥に行かないと見えないよとか
都会とかそういう街明かりがあるところだ
と星なんて見えないよと思った方も
いらっしゃるかなと思います確かにテレビ
とかインターネットとかそれこそ
プラネタリウムそういった場所で見られる
ような
満天の星っていうものは
街中から見ることはできません
しかし都会から
星が1個も見えないということはないん
です
こちらの写真は東京の新宿駅の駅前から私
のスマホの
iPhoneの普通のカメラで撮った画像
になりますで上の方にこうアーチ状にある
のはですね新宿駅の駅の明かりになります
空を取るだけなのに映り込んでしまうそれ
くらい明るい場所なんですが実はこれよく
見るとですね
今まるで囲んだところに
星が写っているんですこれは
夏の大三角と呼ばれる3つの星を結んだ形
それに所属する場所なんですが実際にです
ね私が新宿駅前に行って目で見た時も夏の
大三角の3つの星バッチリ見えておりまし
た
ということはですね新宿駅前でさえ見える
ということはおそらく皆さんの例えばお家
の前とか仕事帰り学校帰りの駅前とかから
でもですね少なくとも夏の大三角の星で
あれば見えているはずだと思うんですよね
つまりですね私たちがもちろん星を見ない
ことが悪いことじゃないっていうのは大
前提としてあるただ私たちってそこに夏の
大三角があるはずなのに見えるわけないよ
と思い込んでいるから見ていないのでは
ないでしょうか
目には入っているはずなのに目に入れてい
ない見えているはずなのに見ていないと
いうことかもしれません
それは私たち自身に置き換えるとすれば
ですね私たちってなんか心の中でこれやり
たいなって思ってるけど実際にやってない
心の中ではわかってるけど行動していない
ことってあったりしませんか私はあります
ありましたそれが私の中では
YouTubeだったんです
私がリコットという名前を名乗り始めて
YouTubeを中心としたSNSで発信
活動始めたのは2020年4月でしたこの
時期どんなことが起こっていたのかという
と新型コロナウイルス感染症の影響による
外出自粛そういった時代でした
私はこのタイミングより前もですねこう
いった星とか宇宙とかをいろんな人に話す
とか広場公園とかで望遠鏡を置いてみんな
で星見ましょうそういったイベントにも
関わっていたんですがこの2020年4月
の外出自粛のタイミングであらゆる
イベントが中止になってしまいました本当
に全てのイベントがここでパタリと終わっ
ていやこれはどうしたものかとやっぱり
それでも私は発信する活動っていうのを
続けたくてこのタイミングで止めるのはや
だなと思ってそこで右も左もわからない
ままこのタイミングでYouTubeを
始めるそういった過去があります
もちろんきっかけはそこなんですがこの後
にですねYouTubeをやりたいなと
いう風にいきなり突然思い始めたわけでは
ありません
実は私の中でこれより前にですね
YouTubeやりたいなっていう思いは
ずっと思っていましただいたい2019年
くらいですかねYouTube見るのは
好きだったのでその中で自分が作るなら
こういう動画作るのになとかですね
星空のことやるならこういうこといいよ
なっていう具体的なイメージまで思い描け
ていたんですが私の中では初めていなかっ
たんですね
私たちって毎日のように何かしらのことを
考えて何かしらのことに気づいて生活して
いるんじゃないかなと思いますそれなのに
例えばいざ自分の可能性っていうものを
探そうとした時になんか全くのゼロから
考えがちなんじゃないかなと思います
もちろん何もないところから何かを
生み出すことも素晴らしい活動ではあると
思うんですが私のようにですね自分の中に
すでにあるはずの思いとか考えとか気づき
とかそういったものの中から可能性を
引き出してみるそして実際にやってみる
そういった手もあるのではないでしょうか
実際に私はですねそこからYouTube
チャンネル始めまして自分の
YouTubeやってみたいなそういう
気持ちを信じて試行錯誤しながら
YouTubeへの動画投稿を続けて
まいりましたそして今ではチャンネル登録
者は3000人以上になっています
もちろんですねYouTube全体で見る
と3000人というのはまだまだ駆け出し
のチャンネルですただ冷静に考えると
3000人以上の人に私の活動を届けると
いうことってYouTubeを始めてい
なかったらできていなかったんじゃないか
なと思います
私たちってやってみたいって思ってるけど
やっていない行動しないっていうことが
ありますよねまあそういった自分のやって
みたいっていうことにチャレンジすること
そういったことって
星空に見えているはずの星を見ようと思っ
て見ることに
似てるんじゃないかなと私は思います
見えないものを見ようとするという前に
見えているものを見ようとする本当は自分
の心の中で思ってることそういったことに
向き合ってみるそれがですね私たちが持っ
てる可能性に気づくための一つの手段と
なるのではないでしょうか
ということで無限の可能性に気づくという
ことと星空の中に星を見つけるそういった
ことを対応させて考えてみました
ただやっぱり私たち新しい環境に飛び込む
とか新しいことを始める可能性に気づいて
も実際に行動することってやっぱり
勇気が必要ですよねこれやってうまくいく
のかなってそういった漠然とした不安も
もちろんあると思います私だってあります
新しいこと始めるときにこれうまくいくの
かなそういったこと絶対考えます
じゃあそんな時どうすればいいんでしょう
かそのヒントも天文学に求めるのであれば
星を星と見つけて
結んでみるそういったですね
星座なんじゃないかなと思いますので正座
の話も少しさせてください
ちょっと見えちゃったけど
星座の話をしますさっきですね名前を知っ
てる星座があるっていう方がですね結構
たくさんいたなと
いうことはわかったんですがじゃあ
そもそも星座とは何か」っていうのがです
ね正式に決まっています今度こそ出します
星座とはですね空を分割した領域のことで
ある
これは国際天文学連合というですね天文学
に関するあらゆる取り決めをする組織が
こういう風に決めているんですねであれっ
て思った方いらっしゃるかと思います
星座とは空を分割した
領域のことである
例えばですねオリオン座という星座冬に
よく見える星座があるんですが今実際に
オリオン座がここに写っています
どこかなと私で説明するときにはオリオン
座ってこんな
砂時計の形とか
蝶ネクタイを縦にした形ですそういう風に
説明することが多いんですねこの線の結び
方は割といろんなところに本とかWeb
サイトなどに書いてあるかなと思うんです
が実はこの線先ほどのですね国際天文学
連合という取り決めをしている組織がこの
線を正式に決めているわけではないんです
あくまでオリオン座とはここですという風
に決めているオリオン座で言うとここから
この部分がオリオン座です国際天文学連合
が正式に決めている星座というのは実は
この部分だけなんですね要するにその中の
線の引き方は決められていないんです
星座って星空の中の住所みたいなものと
言えますここからここはオリオン座中は
自由ですそういったものが正式な一応
星座の決め方になっております
つまりですね実は
星座の線の結び方って自由なんですね
私たちどういう結び方をしてもいいんです
どの点と点をつないでもいいんです
私たちが新しいことを始めるそういった
行動する何かをするっていう時も自由な
発想で
枠組みにとらわれることなく思い切って
自分なりの形を自分なりの点と点のつなぎ
方を作っていいんじゃないかなと思います
もちろんそこにはうまくいくかなそういっ
た不安がありますそれもわかりますその
気持ちはよくわかりますただ新しいことに
取り組んでみることで私たち自身が新しい
価値を作ることができるのではない
でしょうか
価値があるところを探して飛び込んでいく
だけじゃなくて自分で新しいことを始めて
新しい価値を作るそういったことができる
と思います私は天文学の発信を始めたのも
一番最初に何か大きな理由があったわけで
はありませんそのきっかけは縣さんという
方の講演会に行って私もこういう人みたい
になりたいなって思った
憧れの人にですねサインをもらうくらい
そういった方と出会ったのがきっかけに
なりますもちろん今思えばそのピンと来た
こういう人になりたいって思ったのが自分
の得意分野の天文学と発信する活動それが
うまく重なったからかなというふうには
思っているんですが正直その当時はなんか
ピンと来たなやってみたいなそれくらいに
しか思ってませんでした
なんか新しいことを始める理由って大げさ
じゃなくてもいいんじゃないかなと思い
ます
その後もですね私はYouTubeを中心
として様々な活動を展開してきましたこれ
まで私が作ってきた動画のサムネイルを
出してみたんですがまあこう見ても
いろんな
活動やってきましたねその中で中では
計画はしたけどもちろんうまくいかなかっ
たっていうこともたくさんありました
ただですねその中で試行錯誤を繰り返して
新しい活動に取り組んでその中で新しい
価値というものを作ってこれたんじゃない
かなと思います
私にとってのスーパーノヴァとは自分の
やってみたいに向き合って新しい価値を
作っていく
私たちが本当はやってみたいって心の中で
思っていることに向き合ってみるそれに
思い切って始めてみてそこから新しい
価値を作るということができるそうすれば
私たちが無限の可能性に気づくことができ
て一歩を踏み出すことができるのではない
でしょうか
私もやってみたいということに向き合って
ですね彼これ7年以上が経ちますその中で
いろいろな活動を展開してきましたでは
その中でありがたいことに本当にたくさん
の方に届けられているんですが先日嬉しい
ことがありまして
子どもたちに向けてお話をしてください」
っていうふうにですねお願いされまして
実際に話に行ったんですねそして話した後
帰る準備をしてたらですねその話していた
子供たちがちょっと寄ってきてなんか紙と
ペンを持ってたんですよねでは何々と思っ
ていろいろ話したんですけど話し終わった
後に
ここにサイン書いてもらえませんかって
言われたんですよね私も
元々バトンを受け渡される側にから始まっ
たこういった活動なんですけど私も
いろんな活動を通してバトンを受け渡す側
に慣れているのかなと強く実感したそんな
瞬間でした
これからも私は新しい価値を作っていける
ような活動をしていきたいと思いますでは
あなたは
あなたの星空にどんな
星座を描きますか私はこれからの行動で
示していきますご清聴ありがとうござい
ました
[拍手]